il trône majestueux à l'entrée de
l'exposition montée par le souverain
louis saez le cheval symbole de pouvoir
l'art et le pouvoir nous semblait
intéressant d'abord à cause de la
proximité du château de versailles en
tant que lieu de pouvoir parce que nous
sommes dans la galerie des affaires
étrangères donc on s'immisce tarnos
louis 15 qui est un lieu de pouvoir et
donc la représentation en majesté du
cheval nous semblait quelque chose tout
à fait naturel une centaine de pièces
inédites issues des collections royales
et rassembler le cheval est ainsi objet
d'étude de formation et modèles mais
aussi d'éducation comme ce jouet
mécanique du prince impérial daté de
avec près de 40 autres pièces il est
prêté par un collectionneur privé nos
racines sans sur le dos du cheval nous
étions harnacheur scellier la maison a
commencé avec un certain thierry hermès
sous louis philippe en 1837 comme
manufacture de l'arnacoeur scellier et
ce passionné en question est le petit
fils du fondateur d'hermès
emilie maurice hermès qui elle est donc
en 1871 s'en fait un contemporain de
marcel proust emile hermès avait
constitué depuis l'adolescence une
extraordinaire réserve d'objets qui
racontait l'histoire qui portait des
traces
je voulais dire physique sensuelle de
toute la mémoire de l'humanité qui
pendant des millénaires avait marché
avec le cheval du tableau à l'ouvragé en
passant par le célèbre carré
le cheval est ici le roi un souverain
toujours apprécié